as the virus tears
through the cities of south africa
[Music]
the residents of one community are
trying to rescue themselves
welcome to lenesia on the outskirts of
johannesburg
where inhabitants have given up on the
[Music]
government
self-preservation has been taken
in-house
as thousands of people fall ill
akilah nosaka is a single mother who
recently tested positive
for covid19 i do want to be giving you
a little bit of oxygen right before you
take you to hospital
her chest is aching and her mind is
racing
but she doesn't want to stay in an
overcrowded hospital
do you think you will have to go to the
hospital
um no because i've got my kids at home
and i
i mean they need me and i need to get
better
yeah but let's change the filter the
filters need to be changed for covert
patients
that's the head of the community
ambulance service abu bakr saeed
and he's done something remarkable from
his office at the local mosque
he's built a parallel health care system
to treat people
like aquila at home i must be honest
with the government hasn't been doing
much at
all we can't be sitting back and waiting
for the government to do something
because it will never happen
so that's why we needed to be out there
making a difference
together with partner organizations mr
saeed is hurriedly securing advanced
oxygen machines
which turn ordinary bedrooms into
critical care
beds we have over 60 units available for
the community you've essentially created
60 hospital rooms absolutely that's what
it is critical care rooms in this
community
yeah so by having 60 of these is exactly
what we did
we can provide for 60 people at a time
and try and make a difference to 60
lives it's not just one life
it is an extraordinary concept but
home-based
intensive care requires specialist
doctors to oversee it
and sisters fatima and sofia lambert are
part of the team
we found them donning biohazard gear on
the grassy verge of
nightingale street we a south african
doctors are
very very used to improvising
this is what we need to do and we
improvise
we followed them into the home of
resident muhammad saluji
who has been fighting for his life for
the past four weeks
his oxygen levels were worryingly low
and he'd been coughing up blood
in the early hours and speaking a cough
is being induced so he's unable to hold
a long conversation
without him having these dr fatima
prescribes steroids and pain relief but
the burden of care falls primarily
on his loved ones who serve as the
fill-in physician
and the 24-hour nurse and it isn't easy
we could see them struggling with the
oxygen concentrator
[Music]
right we're going to win this be
positive
after 30 minutes or so mr saluji
climbed onto his bed his body aching
with exhaustion
you've had a tough time haven't you
got his testicles
she's got a good team here excellent
dr lambert and dr lambert had one more
house call to make
donning their ppe in the patient's
driveway
she suffers from chronic conditions like
diabetes and high blood pressure
but to the doctor's surprise she seemed
to be recovering from covid19
the first time we saw her how oxygen
levels were sitting
in the 60s 63
and now we're seeing it at 93. okay so
it's a huge huge improvement
the doctors and their machines are
important
but mrs garwood says her daughter sophia
has kept her alive
she looks after me very nicely yeah
and she even sleeps with me at night
she's
also studying so she's working till late
night and then she comes and sleep with
me
all right yeah your daughter is actually
sleeping here with you
yeah she sleeps right here with me okay
right she wouldn't be able to do that in
hospital no no she won't be able to do
that to us
[Music]
now we can breathe the stress and
fatigue
are written on fatima lambert's face but
she says she's determined to keep going
my family is actually complaining
because i'm in icu
i'm also an anaesthetist so i'm an
anatherus an intensivist a mother a wife
you know but
it's the time when we can give to the
community so we
put everything aside and help this
inshallah yeah and then you see
their smiles are our smiles
[Laughter]
[Music]
the coronavirus has torn through
lynnesia
and abu bakr saeed has not been spared
he ran the sabari chisty ambulance
service with his father
and uncle but both men have died from
covert 19.
yet the pandemic has strengthened his
sense of purpose
in a community that's found new ways to
survive
john sparks sky news johannesburg